c'était aujourd'hui la journée la plus
chaude de la semaine il a fait cet après
midi jusqu'à 34° à blois vendôme loges
ou tours durant ces fortes chaleurs les
piscines sont évidemment prises d'assaut
ainsi que les différents lieux de
baignade à joué-lès-tours pas question
de faire un plongeon au lac des
bretonnières qui présente une
prolifération de cyanobactéries
dangereuses pour les humains comme pour
les animaux même interdiction dans la
loire où la qualité de l'eau n'est pas
contrôlé alors la réalité est elle
conforme aux recommandations
samuel colin est allé vérifier sur place
pas de baignade cette saison aux bretons
nière la mairie de joué les tours
annonce la prolifération de
cyanobactéries dans l'eau du lac
l'espace surveiller reste donc fermée
cette année et sur place l'on nous parle
déjà de patrouille de police à la chasse
aux baigneurs en bord de loire à tours
la baignade aussi est interdite
pourtant peu de monde semble s'en
formaliser et c'est en famille que l'on
vient profiter d'un bain de soleil à la
plage des bancs de sable une eau peu
profonde et une sortie inévitable
aujourd'hui il fait tellement chaud en
fait on s'est calé les bords de loire
qui seront accessibles
on n'aurait pas pu déjà avec les jumeaux
aux rues trop chaud quoi une destination
de plein centre ville choisie pour
varier les plaisirs et à la piscine et
puis pour changer un peu le cadre voilà
un peu de d'environnement un peu de
verdure et ben viens ici c'est juste
histoire de faire trempette quasiment
aucun affichage n'est visible hormis sur
la protection des oiseaux comme un
rappel pour certains si l'eau est
interdite
le risque ne saute pas aux yeux pas
tellement dit des fois il ya des
tourbillons mais c'est passé pas si
dangereux que ça une interdiction de
baignade par arrêté municipal reconduit
tous les ans depuis 2007 à cause des
courants mais aussi de la qualité de
l'eau non contrôlée sur le fleuve